في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض دشنا امير
المنطقه منطقه الرياض مشروع ضاحيه الفرسان
كاكبر حي سكني بالرياض يتبع للشركه
الوطنيه للاسكان وذلك على مساحه 35 مليون
متر مربع هذا وياتي المشروع بعد توجيه ولي
العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
لزياده المعروض العقاري
وينضم الينا هنا في الاستوديو رئيس
التنفيذي للوطنيه للاسكان محمد البطيخي
من الرياض نبارك لكم اولا اطلاق هذا
المشروع وخلينا نعرف اكثر عن اكبر
المشاريع او اكبر الاحياء السكنيه في
الرياض ضاحيه الفرسان ايش تفاصيلها اهلا
بك واسعد الله مساءك كل المشاهدين بكل خير
الحمد لله اليوم نسعد بالتدشين ضاحيه
الفرسان
ونتقدم بالشكر الجزيل لصاحب السمو الملكي
الامير فيصل بن بندر بن عبد العزيز على
حضوره وتشريفه وتدشينه هذه الضاحيه التي
تعد ليست الاكبر على مدينه الرياض بل
على مستوى المملكه
ضاحيه بمساحه 35 مليون متر مربع
وتاتي بدعم كبير من القياده ودعم وتوجيه
مباشر من سيدي الامير محمد بن سلمان في
التخصيص اراضي الاسكان اخرها طبعا ضاحيه
خزام واليوم ضاحيه الفرسان
اللي اليوم دشنها
هذه مساحتها 35 مليون متر مربع التحويل
على خمسين الف وحده سكنيه بحول الله بعد
انتهاء كامل مراحلها تتسع لمئتين وخمسين
الف نسمه
بمجموع استثمارات يتجاوز 45 مليار ريال ان
شاء الله بالشراكه مع القطاع الخاص شركه
الوطنيه اليوم كمطور وطني ولاعب وطني كبير
في مجال التطوير العقاري
والخدمات المسانده للتطوير العقاري سواء
الخدمات تجاريه او ترفيهيه او او سياحه او
غيرها فمجموعه الاستثمارات بيتجاوز فيها
45 ونعمل احنا كمطور وطني وممكن وطني في
القطاع العقاري
بدات اليوم الحمد لله الاول مراحل واحنا
نستهدف تطوير يعني مجموعه مشاريع في
الرياض اليوم
ضاحيه الفرسان
اللي حتى راعينا في تصميمها ليس فقط
التصميم الوحدات السكنيه بل اخذ كامل
معايير جوده الحياه والمرافق العامه
والخدمات مش بعيد جوده الحياه او مفهوم
حتى ايضا جوده الحياه بالنسبه للوطنيه
اللي ممكن يتنفذ وكيف تمكنوا اساسا
الشركاء اللي موجودين معكم من تعزيز هذه
الفكره مفهوم جوده الحياه في هذا الحي
وجود كل الخدمات واي احد يفكر انه يشتري
بهالمكان يعني مش المحفز اللي اللي يقدمه
طبعا معاييرها تبدا من التخطيط التخطيط
الحضري او التخطيط لهذه الاراضي والمساحات
بحيث انه تؤخذ في الاعتبار التوزيع
المناطق السكنيه وتوزيع المناطق الخدميه
والتجاريه
بحيث انها تعطي مساحات اكبر للمناطق
المفتوحه
والذات متعدد وايضا تقلل من حركه نقل
السيارات وتشجع على حركه المشاه او
الدراجات تتنوع الخدمات بحيث انه تكون كان
اللي ساكن ساكن في وسط
مساحه اكبر كبير جدا عامه ومملوكه له حركه
المشاه ما تتعدى خمس الى سبع دقائق
للخدمات الرئيسيه مثلا مثل المسجد او
السوبر ماركت الصغير او الحديقه
ناخذ في الاعتبار انه ما تتعدى من خمس الى
سبع دقائق
للخدمات الاكبر من عشر دقائق الى ربع ساعه
هذه بالنسبه لحركه المشاه استخدام المناطق
الحدائق بشكل اكبر نستهدف مثلا زراعه نصف
مليون شجره في في ضاحه الفرسان مجموع
الهدايا تساعد على المشي بشكل كبير
الوحدات السكنيه وتوزيعها مناسب لكثير من
الاسر يعني تعيش في وسط مكان كبير تستخدم
مناطق عامه كثيره اللي ساكن يستخدمها
كانها ملكه انا اشكرك جزيل الشكر ما تبقى
عندي كثير من الوقت يعطيك الف عافيه الله
لنا في استديو التنفيذي الوطني للاسكان
السيد محمد البطيء شكرا لك